is the co-author of racecourse against
white supremacy he'll take your calls
for three hours on book tv's in depth
[Music]
in his new book nazi nexus edwin black
looks at the u s corporations that he
says were directly involved with the
holocaust the event hosted by the park
east synagogue in new york city is an
hour 30 minutes
okay thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen can you hear me
all right thank you for coming out today
to the park youth synagogue to
nahos
to hear this presentation about my book
nazi nexus i know that today there are
many observances all across man
manhattan for yomashawa for holocaust
day
and uh um
i am taken
that all of you thought to come to this
event so that we can discuss
um
what happened during the third reich
that created the nazi nexus
really
it's significant to me
that i am here speaking to you but the
real question is not why i am here the
question is why you are here
and who put you here
hitler put you here
but hitler had help
now who helped him
you know that over the past
decade
i've struggled to answer this question
you know that
my parents were in the holocaust my mom
was on the train to treblinka when she
was uh pushed out of by her mother from
the little window and she was buried in
a mass grave
and
her leg was sticking out in the snow
and
my father came upon her and pulled them
out and they lived in the woods for two
years like defiance
not that group but a different group
and i always thought it was my business
to answer the questions
of how it happened
somebody else discussed what happened
how did it happen
i wrote ibm in the holocaust and i wrote
war against the weak
and i wrote banking on baghdad and
internal combustion
and all these books
and on each one
i answered a specific question
and a few years ago
on a young on a crystal knocked
here in new york and in
orlando
i was asked to connect the dots
and when i did
i realized
that the actual scope
of the holocaust the enormity of the
holocaust the dimension of the holocaust
was determined
by american corporations
each in their own way
i'm going to lay it out for you
you could ask your
questions and maybe one of them will be
able to answer you after i do
one of those corporations
now i'm going to start
at the very basic concept
of the jewish menace
what was here what was hitler's mantra
the jews are our misfortune the
international jewish conspiracy
this gave him the ability to elevate
jew hatred religious hatred outgroup
hatred
from a religious phenomenon
to a global war
against the jews
that the nazis and the third reich would
lead and which they did lead
now where
did hitler get this idea
of an international jewish conspiracy
that controlled
the media
that controlled the banks
that controlled the military
that controlled the governments
that worked with capitalism with
communism with zionism
where did they get the idea
that the world was being dominated and
manipulated by the jews
they got it from the ford motor company
most people know this today
that henry ford
was the number one
anti-semite
in the united states
after world war one
they didn't know it when i wrote my book
the transfer agreement in 1984
which is just being republished in the
coming months
at the time it was not known
the degree to which the ford motor
company
was involved in sponsoring the concept
of the international jewish conspiracy
since then there's been a half a dozen
books
and it's become known but i thought i
would put a chapter in nazi nexus
because ford is at the basis
he's at the base
of the hitler notion that there was not
just a group of people that he did hate
before he knew the name ford but that
his hatred
had a place in a larger global war
henry ford
was also the hero of one of my last
books which was on how he got addicted
to oil henry ford
was a genius
of manufacturing
and a complete
intellectual
idiot
this guy could be suckered by anything
and after world war one
a type script called the protocols of
the elders of zion was shown to him by
zarist agents
and he bought it hook line
and sinker
he quit his job one of the biggest names
one of the wealthiest men
one of the most powerful individuals in
america he quit his job as the president
of ford motor company
he bought a publication called the
dearborn independent
and he used his mass production
techniques
to take pamphleting and a type script
and a whisper and a rumor
and produce an international publishing
phenomenon
the protocols of the elders of zion the
international jew
he reprinted it
he published it in both serial form and
in book form it got translated all over
the world
and it went all over germany
and it came to the attention we're
talking about 1919 we're talking about
1920 it came to the attention of adolf
hitler and he said henry ford is my hero
and even when it came time for henry
ford to be sued for libeling the jews
adolf hitler offered to send his own
shock troops to chicago
hundreds of thousands
of copies of the protocols of the elders
of zion
in german were circulated throughout
germany
by the carload
often with hitler and ford
pictured on the cover
was this the work of one man
no this was the work of the company
itself
the company ford motor company
sold the protocols of the elders of zion
he made it clear you cannot just sell
the model t and our tractors if you are
selling the the ford product you are
selling the protocols of the elders of
zion
the company financed it
the company distributed
this
was an act
of corporate complicity
and so henry ford
was able
to excuse me adolf hitler in the 20s
was able to move forward believing he
was fighting not just against a
different religion
not just a group against a group of
people who were
from poland
but an international
jewish conspiracy
that stretched from new york
to berlin
to london to to jerusalem
now we
move to the next step
where did adolf
hitler get the idea
that jews
were sub-human
bacterial
that it didn't matter
what religion the individual practiced
it mattered what was in the blood
that a jew was defined not by his
his his shabbos
but by his ancestry
and even a jew
who was
who had converted to catholicism or who
would become a lutheran or whose parents
were catholic
or who was a non-observant jew
that person was a drew
was a jew by virtue of his blood
and so
any member of german society
could now be suspect for being
biologically inferior
the fact of the matter was
adolf hitler
wanted a master race
where did he get these ideas of a master
race rasun bloot
race and blood
race and blood did not come from germany
race and blood came from the president
of stanford university
it was american eugenics
at the turn
of the 20th century
the carnegie institution which was a
steel fortune
the rockefeller foundation which was an
oil fortune
and the harriman railroad
estate which was a railroad force
fortune
combined
to take mendel's principles
of heredity
and combine them
into social engineering
they believed
that human beings
could be bred
the way you breed wheat peas
horses pigs
and how do you do that
you eliminate the unwanted stock
and you propagate the wanted stock and
which stock was the one they wanted
the americans
from the period of 1903 to about 1911
wanted a group
to inherit the world
who were nordic
blonde
blue eyed
they didn't want the chinese from the
west
who were coming in at the end of the
19th century
they didn't want the mexicans who had
come in from the south because after the
uh uh
the war with mexico we took over half of
mexico's terror territory they didn't
want hundreds of thousands of east
european and jews coming in from the
east they didn't want the blacks coming
um uh out of the south during the
post-reconstruction period they didn't
want the indians coming off the
reservation they wanted it the way it
was they wanted the way their their uh
pioneer parents had established america
and they wanted germanic they wanted
nordic they wanted blind they wanted
blue-eyed and they felt everybody else
didn't have the right to exist
who was who was behind this
well the agriculture department of the
united states
because they felt that we could
grow people the way we grow corn
and they set up an organization
at cold spring harbor on long island
to study eugenics this was the topic of
my book war against the week
in fact this video that we just saw was
done by the director of war against week
it's now a movie in festival
and they said
that only the blonde blue eyed
stereotype is entitled to live
and this was in 1910
9 1911
and what methods did they have
to eliminate the unwanted
they said we will take away the bottom
tenth
10 percent of the time that was 14
million americans
they wanted them to disappear and after
that 14 million americans were taken
away they would take the remaining
bottom 10th off and then they would keep
slicing off a bottom 10th
until
there was no one left but
themselves method
forced surgical sterilization
marriage pro
pro prohibition
marriage voiding
concentration camps
and public gas chambers
they even entered in 1908 legislation
into the ohio
the ohio state legislature among many
other places
to make it legal for a doctor to write a
prescription
that this man should be put to death
and who was to be put to death
brown-haired
white people meaning the appalachians
the hillbillies
anyone who they thought was
feeble-minded
alcoholics
criminals
at that time you could have a criminal
just by you could be a criminal
just for doing nothing
for being poor they called it vagrancy
sicilians mexicans
blacks chinese
and they said at the end of this process
we will have a master race
it'll be utopia
we don't want to hurt anybody we want to
help the world
because we believe
that you are not
born into prostitution prostitution is
born into you you are not born into
poverty poverty is born into you
and they said if we get rid of the jews
and if we get rid of the black people
and if we get rid of the uh chinese we
gravity the mexicans we will get rid of
the prostitution the criminality will
get rid of disease etc etc
and all of this
was studied in the 20s
by adolf hitler
the books were translated
by the nazi publishing company he
studied them in prison
and if anyone bothered to read and
translate the full
copy and text of mind conf
and study those particular passages
you will see that he specifically talks
about the american legislation for
eugenics and how he would pattern his
new reich society after the american
model
and so adolf hitler
took his pre-existing nationalism his
pre-existing jew hatred
now politicized by henry ford
and he medicalized it
and he turned it into a race war
what was it
that the nazis were fond of saying
including hitler's personal circle
national social socialism
is just biology in practice
and so we understand
that world war ii was not as much
a war of territorial conquest and
economic plunder
it was
a eugenic war a biology war
backed up
by a murderous military
and so
adolf hitler
would write fan mail
to american eugenesis
saying you are your work is my bible
and now
the theories of adolf hitler the
campaigns of adolf hitler the programs
of adolf hitler were to do exactly what
the americans had legislated
had proposed had outlined we had
concentration camps they were in new
jersey
they were in massachusetts they were in
connecticut
we had
marriage voiding 27 states
had
racial laws against marriage virginia
had an entire bureau to unmarried people
that wasn't even overturned until 1960
loving versus virginia
racial integrity act
we had
public
gas chambers being debated by the
prisons by the mental institutions we
had tubercular milk being given out to
delinquents in lincoln illinois to get
rid of them
on the theory that if you gave a
eugenically inferior person tubercular
milk from a tubercular cow
if he wasn't unfit he wouldn't die
and then in 1920
in the 1920s
a figure no less than oliver wendell
holmes
ruled in the famous case buck versus
bell when they wanted to sterilize not
just carrie buck but her daughter and
her mother
it is better
for all the world to sterilize three
generations of imbeciles
and the president that the supreme court
made
was vaccination
for syphilis
if we can vaccinate
for syphilis we can get rid of these
people that's bacterial that's nazi
intervention
oliver wendell holmes
in fact
when the nazis
were brought to nuremberg
they quoted oliver wendell holmes in
their defense
they quoted the california statutes
where one-third to one-half of all four
sterilizations were done this didn't
take place in alabama this took place in
connecticut this took place in minnesota
this took place in massachusetts this
took place in california
it actually took place in 27 states some
60 000 americans
mainly without their knowledge mainly
women
were forcibly sterilized
by the government on the grounds of
being unfit
their only crime
was that they were designated
not to live
they would have preferred the gas
chambers adolf hitler says why should i
wait for that i'll just use the gas
chambers
and if you
and if you study the way
the nazis went in from territory to
territory and first they identified the
jews and they had these concepts
of the full jew the half jew the quarter
jew the 16th jew where did that
mathematics come come from that came
from harry laughlin of the carnegie
institution
the national origins act of 1928 in in
the united states congress
he defined this and he was given an
award from the third reich for doing it
that is how they propounded the concept
of the nuremberg laws based on the
american mathematics the
the american concepts and this is the
carnegie institution and the rockefeller
foundation
there's much more in this topic
about 590 pages more in my book war
against the weak but there's enough to
show you that this is a dot
that cannot be ignored remember ladies
and gentlemen we are not talking
about collaboration with the third reich
we are not talking about people
in england who sold the third reich
buttons and bows
and traded with the enemy we are talking
about the indispensable pivots
of the outlines
of hitler's holocaust
so as long as we're on the topic of
eugenics
let's talk about rockefeller that's oil
money
rockefeller
paid millions
and so to carnegie institution millions
to establish american-style eugenics
in nazi germany
and in pre-nazi germany
they knew exactly what they were doing
and they funded hitler's
most virulent anti-jewish eugenic
doctors the nazi doctors
funded by
rockefeller funded by the carnegie
institution and by the way the american
museum of uh of uh natural history had a
big piece of this too they're right here
in in new york
in fact the fan mail that was sent there
by adolf hitler personally is no longer
available to be seen
so rockefeller
funded
these nazi doctors
including the number one nazi doctor
and the number one nazi doctor
was a guy called atmar veshore
and for sure
believed in twins
and they believed
that investigating
the mystery of twins
would reveal
the secrets to multiply the the uh uh
the generations of the third right
and to radically reduce the presence of
those deemed biologically unfit to live
now
in america
you had to find a twin here and a twin
there
in nazi germany
himmler said
all twins must register
and report for examination
now for sure who was funded by
rockefeller and it was only one of many
had an assistant and that assistant's
name was
mengele
you know him personally
you were in auschwitz
then you will know that what i'm saying
is the next the next sentence i say is
correct you will know that when the
trains came in with the dogs and the
noise and with the soldiers screaming
that above the tumult
they said
we want twins
we want twins
anybody here heard that
you did
okay we want twins and those twins were
exempted from the gas chambers
for the time being
and they were sent to a barracks and
horrible medical experiments were done
they fused together their their veins
they put blue eyes into brown eyes
and the world
could not comprehend
what kind of a monster
would do this kind of experiment
but the fact is
rockefeller
foundation knew what kind of a monster
it was because every week mengele
was filing important clinical reports
important clinical diagnosis autopsies
and they were motorcycled to his
rockefeller fellowed
atmar for sure
for review
and that group of people
after the war founded a brand new
science
no longer called eugenics the new
science that these nazis founded was
called genetics
same people
same laboratories
same foundations
same money
thank you
that's another
dot and a big one
so
we have an international jewish
conspiracy we have jews not worth living
we have jews in international jewish men
minister must be destroyed
now how is that going to be done on a
horse
who took hitler off the horse and
motorized the third reich
gm it was not ford
it was general motors it was general
motors from detroit
it was alfred sloan the president
working through the holy owned
subsidiary opel which was the largest
automobile maker in nazi germany and in
europe
who personally
supervised
the motorization
of the third reich now it is true that
germany had made many uh beautifully
crafted uh automobiles you can see them
in antique museums but they made them
one at a time
they made them in
in special garages but they did not mass
produce them
and until
until sloan
k and kettering
went to hitler
and said let us
take you off the horse
and motorize you
it wasn't until that occurred that
hitler became fascinated
with the prospect he loved cars and he
thought that this was modern science
modern technology
the modern way
and sloan said
i will restore your employment
because everybody knows
that
the automobile industry is the keystone
of commerce of commercial economic
success
i will make for you the blitz truck for
the blitz creek
and station them along the borders
and so general motors was stationing the
um
the spare parts and the blitz trucks
along the polish border in the two weeks
before uh september 1st 1939
and now you're gonna have to build
something called the autobahn
and you're going to need something
called oil because you got no cars you
got no auto bomb and you got no oil
you're going to have to go that way in
that way for the oil
and you will be able to project
your power
all across europe
he made these vehicles primarily for the
vermont and he made them secretly
through interlocking directorships
and executive committees that controlled
the uh
german subsidiary
so that they could have deniability in
the hope that i would not come along and
tell it to you
and so
it wasn't enough
to bring the terror of the nazis over
land general motors made the ju-88
bombers
the engines
land mines
torpedoes on land
air
and sea
they brought hell
and terror
and bolstered hitler's war against all
of humanity you must ask yourself
what kind of a holocaust would it have
been on horseback
do not ask me to answer that question i
will leave it for your imagination
what kind of a holocaust would it have
been
without an international jewish
conspiracy
remember
jews
have been persecuted from place to place
from place to place
for
millennia
millennia
what kind of a holocaust would have been
without the master race
what kind of holocaust would have been
in bankruptcy
without the equivalent
of millions
of dollars at a time when there were
bread lines in the united states
and then you may ask well what kind of a
holocaust would have been if hitler
didn't get all all the names
and that's where ibm comes in
ibm the solutions company
they went to hitler and they said
we're the solutions company there's no
solution we won't give you
and ibm
was the master of information technology
the people listening to my voice today
the young people
your grandkids
they think information age was born in
silicon valley it was born in berlin
in 1933.
what is the information age who can
define it
i will define it for
for you it is the
individualization of statistics
prior to ibm
you could count
but you could not tabulate
now to achieve the goals of the
holocaust
required the resources of a computer but
in 1933 there was no computer what they
what
did exist and what all of you remember
is the hollerith punch card
and the punch card could do pretty much
what most computers could do but slower
it stored the information in in in holes
punched into rows in columns
and so when hitler said i'd like to know
just
who are the jews
because they're everywhere and some of
them are wearing black cats and have
little uh curls and some of them are
bankers and go to and go to and go to
church
so
ibm under the micromanagement of thomas
j watson
the president of ibm
working directly around the corner
at 590 medicine
and you did not know this
but now we're here in the shadow of the
ibm building
ibm developed
a census
and by punching in
in one row
the mother tongue
in another row the profession another
role the nationality in another row the
religion another road the city the city
at the rate of twenty four thousand
cards per hour
like that they could identify all the
jews of polish extraction in the city of
berlin who were engaged in the fur trade
like that
once they were identified
they could be subjected
to the eugenic laws
the persecution laws in fact ibm
systematized co-planned and organized
all
six phases of the holocaust the
identification of the
jews the expulsion from society
they cross referenced all the
directories
three
the confiscation of their assets all the
banks all the financial institutions on
ibm punch punch cards
four the ghettoization of the jews
all of a sudden the jews pick up one day
they're out of their homes the next day
they're all cramped into specified
flats and apartments crammed up in a
slum all organized eared
five
the deportation of the jews
all the trains in europe ran on
hollywood punch cards i interviewed the
guy at 22 pavilion
who uh
ran the trains in krakow that went to
auschwitz
and even fixed the extermination of the
jews
the auschwitz tattoo
ibm number
that's how it started they always said
we were never in auschwitz they were in
auschwitz i found them in the phone book
on page 50.
i published it in the village voice
they were across they were in every
concentration camp you can go to the
holocaust museum and you'll find a
hundred thousand books on every aspect
of the holocaust in concentration camps
not one will mention the fact except
mine ibm and the holocaust will mention
the fact that every concentration camp
had an ibm customer site the name of
that ibm customer site the hollerith of
thailand
and the hollywood of thailand was in the
arbeit einsatz meaning the labor
assignment bureau
it was across the gate in dhaka it was
across from the
parade plots in mauthausen it was in
auschwitz ii in poland
it was in buchenwald
they even developed extermination by
labor they developed a couple of
different cards
all by hand custom made that would
identify what your skills were i'm a
mechanic i'm a brick layer i'm a tailor
i'm an optician
and then they would cross reference that
with all the jobs that were needed for
slave labor whether you needed an auto
mechanic or whether you needed a someone
to build a barracks or maybe you need
some medical corps whatever it was they
would move them back and forth across
nazi europe and worked them to death and
ibm even had
a code
for the destruction of the physical
destruction of the of the jews
their code for every concentration camp
was code 3 was death by natural causes
code
6
was zander behandlunk special handling
the gas chamber that means that an ibm
en engineer
had to specifically specifically
differentiate between death by natural
causes he also had one for execution
they had one for suic suicide and those
jews who were killed by sending them to
the gas chamber they had to print up all
the cards they had to attend to all the
machines and yes
they serviced the machines on site every
two weeks
the machines were never rented excuse me
the machines were never sold they were
only leased the cards could only use the
ibm cards and if anybody tried to make
their own ibm would actually sue them
for copyright infringement
in the case
in the case of gm
there was
it was jew hatred
and political goal
in the case of ford it was jew hatred
and political goal
in the case of rockefeller it was
biological hatred and a political goal
in the case of carnegie it was
biological hatred and a political goal
in the case of
ibm
it was never
about the national socialism it was
never about the anti-semitism it was
always about the money
business was their middle name
you have to ask yourself
you will tell me what kind of the
holocaust could it have been
on horseback
without a master race
without an international jewish
conspiracy
without a biological wherewithal
and without the names in biological
excuse me in alphabetical order
in comes the truck out comes the colonel
with a list
of all the jews in the town i want
everybody here right away
there always would have been a holocaust
without these corporations but the size
and scope of the holocaust
was actually determined
by the velocity of the cooperation and
contribution and complicity
of these key
major corporations they're not the only
ones i didn't mention coca-cola with
fonta i didn't mention chase now i did
mention
chase bank i didn't mention many many
many of them
but these are the ones
that had the indispensable involvement
that shaped the holocaust
these are the ones
that created
the unmistakable
nazi nexus
thank you
and now i'll uh take your questions we
have a mic here
not this one
okay
i'll take your questions on any uh on
any topic uh
yes okay how does this is it
make it work
okay
uh who has a question first
all right go ahead ma'am uh what what is
your name
sophia yes i'm a survivor all right just
second we have to mic you up
you're a survivor of the warsaw ghetto
yes another camps but my question is bad
austin that we see now coming out in
mass
is that part of ibm uh
cooperation okay
the first question
is about bob arlson
the international tracing service
how did they trace them
ibm gave 17
machines holocaust museum
i'm answering it the holocaust museum
worked for many years
to liberate
this massive
collection of slave labor commercial
involvement and insurance
and holocaust insurance information
and then they hijacked it as you all
know you've all been in the struggle to
to release your
documents and to make it available it's
all been computerized and they're
claiming the computers can only exist in
one place in their museum in uh in
washington dc so the bot arlison is part
of the i is is part of the ibm story
after the holocaust and so yes bob
arlson is part of the story excuse me
but i have seen
some cards some index cards where you
have letters and names that that must
have come through some
some
computerized mecha okay
the uh
the challenge
the challenge is to understand what
cards were scribbles
and stamped and what cards were punched
with holes in them not every file card
or index card was an ibm punch card but
the question is when you see a file card
was it then submitted to the ibm system
the answer to that is
when it's stamped hollywood or fast when
it's handwritten when it's hand typed
and stamped hollerith or fast ibm
registered then you know it was done by
the ibm system and by the way
each of these cards was individualized
was customized some had double 20 some
had 10 the ones that sent the jews to
auschwitz had 10 the ones that were uh
for the rasanov
had a
double 40 there were all different types
of these cards and ibm had to ask them
remember what do you want to happen
and then they said this is how we can do
we can only do this far because the
technology only allows us to do this
much and that's why i say that ibm
co-planned these aspects of
of the holocaust because they actually
gave the margins of what could and could
not be done another question yes ma'am
just a minute please let me come to you
what is your name catherine
and i'm a child survivor of auschwitz as
i told you anyhow your presentation
makes me breathless and speechless has
any of this company been confronted with
this i mean it seemed to be common
knowledge what you are telling us has
any of these companies
been confronted with this
i am confronting you
you are confronted
let me tell you the reaction
ford motor company
first denied it
and then they said mr black you are
right we have we we apologized they took
all all their records they burned them
on to a dvd and the federal expressed
them to me
general motors
tried to um uh intimidate many people
out of um revealing this story they even
tried to intimidate the u s congress
and ultimately
after my initial investigation in the uh
um in in in the jta and internal
combustion they too apologized and said
yes we have done it and now they're
giving me electric cars and hydrogen
cars to drive around uh to show that
that they really are repenting uh the
carnegie institution and the rockefeller
uh have indicated that they are sorry
for what they have done as for ibm
you all know that money talks and
everything else walks
the ibm machine that i saw has been
removed the holocaust museum pixelated
over the logo of the ibm machine until i
got the auditor general to remove that
pixelization to restore the original
picture the ibm machine is gone claiming
that
too many people were looking at it and
they replaced it with another ibm
machine not the one you know about with
the logo on top but with a faded
decal on the side if you look at the
floor you'll see two holes in the marble
where they have pulled out the original
glass case and move and and and move and
moved it in
they are they have been confronted
but
some people prefer to confront them with
lawsuits some people prefer to confront
them with documentation which is what i
do and ultimately
they avoid the confrontation if they
have enough money let me take another
question
yes ma'am
just a minute what is your
is
name
comes from jewish parents no no he is a
descendant of
a cocker fella rockefeller
okay
first of all
it doesn't matter who his parents were
his his his grandparents people said
that hitler himself had jewish blood
that doesn't matter what matters is this
rockefeller money
had the money and at a time when uh
people were standing in bread lines gave
the equivalent of millions to the third
rec to establish eugenic in in
institutions may have your name
elliot i'm just a guest here my question
to you is you told us some horrific
information about the united states
local legislators in ohio please like
that what connection does this have with
current ideas at the time of social
darwinism
the man asked about the concepts of
social darwinism social darwinism had
nothing to do with darwin
darwin was not not not involved in
social darwinism but
those who came after him applied his
concept of the lower species to mankind
which was never his intention they did
use the concept of social
darwinism but basically it was social
and engineering it was a utopia they
were trying to build a utopia and the
way to build a utopia or the thousand
year reich was to get rid of all these
people who did not conform to their
stereotype if anybody knows the word
utopia its greek roots mean nowhere
there is no utopia but they tried to
make one who else has a question let me
take this gentleman
may i have your name
my name is mark mark panker i
appreciate everything you've been doing
i've read some of your books
uh i'd like to talk about something i
saw on television yesterday
where uh
i think it was on a glenn beck show
where he was being
shown that uh
today
the government wants to take blood
samples and dna
of
children
without
the parent's approval
are you aware of that
i didn't see the glenn beck show last
night i've been on it several times i
didn't see it last night goes on i was
on my way up up here but
um
after eugenics
comes a new one new genix and new genix
is our 21st century version of what was
done in the 20th century in the first
decades of the 20th century and it will
define who has a right to live based not
upon national flags and uh and ethnic uh
criteria but on profitability
on whether or not you are um
corporately acceptable who is leading
the charge deleting the charge is the
insurance companies who claim that if uh
you are ill or if your grandparents were
ill you constitute a very special risk
and so we have in we have an
anti-discrimination in anti-genetic
discrimination act
which was
passed unanimously in the house and as
soon as you see any legislation passed
unanimously in the house you know it's
going nowhere in the senate
and
um i'd have an extensive section on
on on this in um war against the weak
but you should know that the concept of
eugenics the concept of
what the british legislature calls the
genetic ghetto
is alive and well and is being driven by
high investment from the
brightest and least bright on wall
street and in the scientific community
and all of these people need to look
back at their tradition the tradition
they may not sense and understand that
in the midst of their bright light of
technologic achievements there is a dark
shadow who else has a question
sir
what is your name please my name is kurt
i was just wondering what is the
complicity of the german corporations
the complicity of the german
corporations is complete it is well
known it is highly documented
they admit it they pay for it they
sponsor
uh donations they sponsor memorials they
sponsor programs uh ibm and the
holocaust was first published by a
german company called bertelsmann
the new addition has just come out from
dialogue press
what is not been accounted for is and
what is the final frontier of
accountability is the
american complicity um because these
german corporations many of whom were on
the verge of bankruptcy did not work in
a vacuum and you see the reason that i'm
engaged in what i'm engaged in the
reason this is this is important the
reason that leo rector who i i i thank
for inviting me here in nahos and the
reason all of you are involved in your
mantra of never again the reason for
this is not only to gain justice for
yourself but for justice for future
generations and
representative
smith from new jersey has held hearings
with yahoo and with microsoft
saying uh what ibm did in nazi germany
you are now doing with china in uh um
on
on the internet
um uh
i am not seeking um justice
just for the generations around me i'm
seeking for justice for everyone because
as we all know it's the jews first and
everybody else second
who else has a question
uh here's a question from this gentleman
i was delighted with good exploring i
just want to know one thing where would
american jews
in that time what did they do
okay
that's the book i don't talk about
that's my that's the transfer agreement
okay
the jews uh the american jewish
community american jewish congress
fought
these were the
eastern european jews they fought like
hell
and they led the international boy cut
against nazi germany
and the jewish war veterans marched uh
on uh on march 15th down the streets of
of of of new york march 15th 1933
and at madison square garden there was
uh the epicenter of a million people
around the country protesting hitler
march 27 1933
it was uh
covered in in the transfer agreement the
american jewish committee which had been
the leading defender of the jews um
during all these prior decades was very
sha-sha on the issue of uh protesting
against the third reich being because
this time it was not sasha and olga who
was subject to the kozaks it was uncle
jaime and uncle friedrich in uh in in in
their own family who were subject to rep
to reprisals and the same came for brene
breth um but there was always the
question
relief or rescue
relief or rescue
do you help the jews
by giving them money or do you fight the
regime and bring it down
and it's a very complicated story and
the answer that i gave you is only a
fragment of the answer that i could give
you
let me uh go to another question did you
have everyone there
um i'm gonna just try to go around to
you i'm gonna pass this to you
a quickie and then give it back to me
okay yes my name is esther fall
i want to know did the president of the
united states was aware of of these
companies the help in germany
okay
the second one you mentioned chase
chase manhattan bank and another bank i
don't recall which one were involved
with that how they were involved and the
third one and what do you think what's
going to be in united states
okay
that's a lot of questions
the first question
what was the first question
did the president of the united states
you mean roosevelt
of course he roosevelt
roosevelt was
where roosevelt got a lot of money from
watson and ibm for his election you know
he didn't carry
many of
the areas around here for election but
he carried a lot up in his neck of the
woods
let me tell you something
i've reviewed 20 000 documents of i of
ibm
carbons originals type scripts telegrams
whatever ibm did in holland in poland in
nazi germany in portugal
the united states government was the
postman
diplomatic pouch commercial out of
shades how the heck did the machines the
census machines get out
from uh uh
nazi occupied poland into romania in
time for the romanian census the united
states was actually a full partner in
this and then
uh
after the war
when uh the united states
um excuse me
when europe was in shambles when europe
was burning and when and and when people
were starving and where p and where
families were separated ibm came in with
a war claim
for lost
shipping boxes
and for scotch tape
and they recovered all of the profits
that were locked away for ibm through
pre-agreement
um in uh swiss banks
i have a letter dated july 4th 1945 in
which the head of the czechoslovakian
subsidiary says
i did just what you said i hid the money
in geneva everything is fine uh the ibm
reports were actually typed on the
typewriter that i have um cross-checked
of the u.s embassy in bur
in berlin
uh the diplomatic pouch as i say was
used ceaselessly the commercial attaches
i hope that answers that question what
was the second question
well
there were a number of banks but let me
just say this
uh a number of banks it's all just
finance
just finance nobody none of the banks
made uh with the exception of maybe the
uh
uh the you the ubs uh none of the banks
was involved in making punch card
machines none of the banks was involved
in slave labor it was just fi financing
and
pardon me
how'd they finance it they financed it
through
spider webs of connections for instance
when general motors
wanted to get foreign exchange to pay to
pay for its uh its parts from nazi
germany nazi germany says we don't have
the foreign currency we'll give you
pencils and we'll give you christmas
lights and you can sell those in latin
america when you get those monies you
can trade them off for dollars was done
through various kinds of transfer
agreements and remember i wrote the book
the transfer agreement and i know
something about that and your third
question was what's going to happen in
in the united states leo will have to
have me back another time who else has a
question this gentleman here
the technicians of ibm during the war in
europe enabling the germans to commit
their crimes
were the technicians enabling the
germans to commit their crimes not only
were they enabling it
we are talking about what would happen
with rifles without bullets what would
happen with the punch cards with punch
card machines without punch cards they
were the exclusive printer of the punch
cards uh the machines had to be sent it
had to be wired
they had to train people how to use them
remember these were complicated machines
not everybody could use these machines
the technicians knew exactly what was
going on because when you're in
auschwitz and you have to differentiate
how to punch a card whether a a man has
been hung
dropped dead
committed suicide
or
been sent to a gas chamber that takes a
lot of
involvement you know there were
thousands and thousands
of concentration camps across europe in
which people of all nationalities and
all religions and all social segments
went in and out of on a daily basis
millions of people but the one day
population capacity of all concentration
camps put together was between 325 and
375
000
that
is traffic management
that was the magic of ibm and its
technicians
next
another question for for you
uh could you please explain uh where
germany
got the oil in order and gasoline uh to
run these trucks where did that come
from
well that's my book banking on baghdad
oh i'm sorry that's my book internal
combustion i'm sorry my book internal
combustion
they they got some from romania
but they worked with the mufti of of
jerusalem
no no they got from british petroleum
uh anglo petroleum oil company and i've
checked their archives uh which changed
their name to ang to anglo iranian and
anglo uh and and turkish petroleum over
various iterations
um ultimately became british petroleum
and uh they were selling oil to the
nazis um but what was most important is
that the arabs were uh engineering oil
to the nazis through the mufti of of
jerusalem and encouraging the nazis to
send jews to um to death camps and this
is the mufti of jerusalem and i believe
this is another area in which the
holocaust which you are fighting the
holocaust museum to include this this
history who else has a question in the
bank
bar me
in jerusalem
no no wonder
you have a question
as a muslim speaker he was a muslim
his name was hussaini he was a muslim
yes
yes i'm the one good i am miriam stern
i'm really
not embarrassed to say i never heard of
you i never read a book and i'm shocked
by the whole thing and i'm wondering how
do you get your message out so that more
people know besides speaking to small
groups of the converted for instance is
there a documentary are you planning a
document
okay the question is how do we reach the
mass media
um
not just small groups like like this
thank you for asking your question the
reality is i do
scores of events every year and i give
the message to small groups of a hundred
and as many as fifteen hundred at a time
i speak to uh
survivors i speak to young peo to young
people i speak to christian groups to
jewish groups i speak to all sorts of
groups as for a documentary there is a
documentary out right now called war
against the week you can find it at war
against week movie dot com it's in the
festivals it tells the eugenic story
that i spoke of carnegie and rockefeller
and mengele
it is uh won the best movie of the year
award from um uh the beverly hills film
festival i have other movies in
production which i cannot discuss at
this time
um
i write for the cutting edge news which
you can find at thecuttingedgenews.com
and i also have a personal website which
you might take notice of it's
edwinblack.com we
we um uh not only do i speak to people
who know this information but the reason
i speak is because there are still many
people who don't know this information
and no and no no matter what i have told
you
no matter what i've published i've only
scratched the surface
all right
thecuttingedgenews.com we reach about a
million people a month yes ma'am my name
is evelyn
and i would like to know i mean i
understand now you you have many
sponsors but at the beginning who
sponsored you you you have to travel a
lot you have a lot of weight all right
the question was how much time do we
have leo as much as we want okay good
i i need some water
all right
who uh who who sponsors me
where do i get the money to uh
to travel et cetera et cetera
i have no foundation grants
the perpetrators do not sponsor me
i'm not a historian for sale
i speak all over the country and i'm
sponsored by university groups
or
churches synagogues federations
but i but i came up yesterday on amtrak
using my points and i stayed in a very
inexpensive
hotel which is my arrangement with leo
because i'm i'm so interested to uh
speak to you for folks um
i assure you if one of the uh major
corporate criminals decided to
investigate itself they would get the
big holocaust museum historians they
would pay them a couple hundred dollars
an hour and uh the and that would be on
uh on the outside um uh i'm not for sale
my information is not for sale and
it's objective and when i thought that
henry ford did a lot to get this country
off of um
oil and into an electric car i wrote the
book internal combustion i said so
without compunction when i knew that
henry ford uh was the biggest holocaust
and ideological uh sponsor of adolf
hitler in the early 20s i wrote the
transfer agreement and the um the uh
and nazi nexus um so um it's a constant
battle to tell the truth but it's never
a constant battle to have the truth be
re remembered who else has a question
i'm getting a lot of questions but
you're closer i'm a little weak so i'm
going to ask you first my name is branja
is anybody else doing that kind of
research
similar to yours
no
yes hi my name is rita i have two
questions one is
um did the involvement of the american
corporations in nazi germany change once
america got into the war or not because
when rabbi weissmundle wanted to trade
jews jewish lives for trucks the
american and other uh free nations of
the world didn't want to give him the
money because they said they can't give
money to a uh to into an enemy
uh territory that was one question
second wait give me that question again
okay
in other words the ibm and all these
different corporations were all
headquartered in nazi germany and in
poland and all in occupied territory
but america wasn't in the war yet once
america entered the war did that change
did they get out what did they do was
mike weissmandel yeah
if they have to do with your question
okay whatever was that group that the
working group from czechoslovakia do you
have a second question yes the other
second question is i've been raised my
whole life you know by german this you
know by germa that maybe we shouldn't be
buying american this okay
okay
okay
let me answer your questions
when
during the uh hitler came to power on
january 30th of 1933
the anti-jewish laws went into effect
all almost
immediately the nuremberg law of 1937
kristallnacht 9
1938 uh the world war ii started at 6
a.m or as some polish people like to say
three o'clock in the morning on
september 1st 1939 we were not dragged
into the european war until pearl harbor
was bombed
um
uh during the uh initial 30s uh it would
um
there was no law against um working with
nazi germany there was a boycott yet uh
the boycott was not only the jewish
there was the um the unions there was
the uh christians there were the
jehovah's witnesses there are lots of
people who were being persecuted by by
the third reich in order to distance
themselves
from nazi germany they started to run
things through geneva and through paris
and through sweden and other areas it
became increasingly difficult in um
to do business with germany after 1937
but it was done in fact it became the
question of the house on american
activities committee sometimes called
huak which began to investigate
collaborators with the third reich of
which there was no greater collaborators
than the ones that i have mentioned
there was no greater collaborators than
the ones that i have mentioned um uh
during um even after we declared war
excuse me even after war was declared on
us in december of 1941
the americans continued to do business
with these nazi companies through
intermediaries kind of in the same way
the oil companies do business with
prohibited companies now through
subsidiaries in fact um
i have a document that i published in
ibm in the holocaust in which
the guy says in czechoslovakia well mr
watson and he handled all this very
personally we re-labeled our nazi
machines as czechoslovakia machines and
they'll never know so the answer to your
question is they did
continue
to work with the nazi regime through in
through into intermediaries in the case
of general motors they worked through uh
some
subsidiaries in denmark your other
question was
what was your other question again
oh should we boycott american companies
all right look
look
i use ibm products they're deadly
accurate
um
we can't boycott companies now
for what was going on then
uh
because we can't even send an email to
get the boycott going well without ibm
involved uh but i um
but i should say that many of these
companies have confessed their guilt or
with the exception of of ibm
or apologized the issue of reparations
is somebody else's uh is a different
discussion and i would say here that
in fact
i'm going to stop for a minute
you said who else is doing this work
i don't take corporate money
so if these companies were not that big
and did not have that much money to buy
off all the institutions in question
and certain unnamed jewish organizations
there'd be many more like me
so i'm i am the only one and i don't
take any of their money and that's why
we need not to boycott them we need to
confront them
with the with the truth what they need
to do is they need to take a page from
their nazi clients
confess what they did apologize and move
on who has a question yes ma'am
how are you dear
my name is esther i wanted to find out
after the war
mccarthyism was rampant they were afraid
of of the soviet union
infiltrating the american scene among
the jews
and of course
they paid a high price in hollywood but
nobody ever
brought on anything about the
involvement of the nazi and how many
nazis you know sympathizers in the
united states there was no connection
never brought out at all about the nazis
only about the russians
well there was a lot uh the reference to
the mccarthy
er era did
try to find
a um
a communist under every rock but in the
prior period they did try to find a nazi
sympathizer under every rock
thank you very much
this is my daughter thank you sweetie
have i ever been threatened do you think
a guy in a golf shirt with a logo could
threaten me
ibm gm is just not going to happen
what uh what ibm has been doing for the
past decade is they've been hiding
they have failed to answer they have not
answered any of the jewish or
organizations they have not answered
answered any of the
the
leading independent historians they have
bought themselves a bunch of museums
they have bought themselves a bunch of
uh of uh of pro
programs they bought themselves a bunch
of historians and they've been able to
wheedle themselves out of the uh out of
accountability when the gypsy sued them
in in geneva they fought for years with
this underfunded group and they
basically didn't say we didn't do it
they said statute of limitations uh
i'm always here for ibm if they need to
find me
who else has a question you asked a
bunch let's go with this guy back here
my name is max
i have
difficulty to understand one statement
about ibm
assuming that ibm wouldn't exist
extermination would proceed anyway
because when germans were coming to any
city in any place in poland they were
just saying every jew has to come
together
so without having
exact statistics or names of everybody
the extermination would
be performed all right the question is
would the extermination have proceeded
without the ibm he says i that the nazis
would have come into town and said all
the jews in the come to the
center of the square and identify
yourself you think all these not these
jews are going to come in and say hello
i'm a jew put me in the truck send me to
auschwitz this was the whole point and
first of all i should say once again
there would have always been a holocaust
a bad one
without ibm without gm without ford
without carnegie without rockefeller but
the size and scope of this holocaust of
hitler's
holocaust the astronomical numbers were
a function of the of of of the corporate
complicity it's one thing to come in
with a bullhorn on a gm truck and say
all jews assemble at noon it's another
thing to come in with an alphabetized
list of address the bank accounts
everything and say we know who you are
everybody on this list
show up and if you're not here
we will pick you up and if someone is
hiding you we will kill them and don't
forget the work of ibm was not limited
to
to statistics and counting they ran the
banks for confiscation they ran the
trains for um uh
for the uh
the uh deportation and they even
developed a system called extermination
by labor which allowed the nazis to work
a man to death at some needed task
before they would extinguish his life
who else has a question
also at least everybody who had artwork
they knew exactly what valuable arts uh
the ibm i'm sure they catalogued that as
a
as well let's get to this gentleman here
yes hi my name is lou thank you for the
presentation really
phenomenal i just wanted to mention that
the we're still being heard today by the
protocols of the elders of zion it's one
of the most popular uh items in arab
countries and that
gives them the
uh reason to
to do what they're doing
and the question was what about the arab
countries that still work with the
protocols
okay
the um
the holocaust
and the in the war against the jews was
stopped in may of 1945 in europe and was
continued in the middle east by the arab
countries with the help guidance and
supervision of escaping nazi generals
colonels and lieutenants and
corporations the protocols of the elders
of zion is a big ticket in the
arab world and of course
was part of a continuing move movement
that was begun and led by the
mufti of jerusalem he was
recommended to be slated for war crimes
by the u.n that never occurred
that was in my book banking on baghdad
which there are not too many copies left
and
the reason he was exempted is because
uh because of the oil pressures at that
time now those who have asked why
there's a phrase in my book nazi nexus
that thanks to holocaust museum for not
including any of this
information should know that there's an
unwritten rule at the holocaust museum
that no american corporation can be
implicated
in its uh in its permanent exhibit and
there you're not going to find any gm
you're not going to find any ford you're
not going to they've got a wonderful
eugenics
project uh and display there's no
rockefeller mengele
et cetera et cetera who else has a
question
yes ma'am
how standby
goldie goldie goldie yeah what about
the people who denied the holocaust
for example
the the president from the palestinian
he wrote a book nobody says anything
about it he denies the whole thing
you you mean the president from iran
a boss
okay
let me just cut to the chase
let me just not dance around it
the iranians
are now trying to do or the president of
iran i should say is now trying to do in
12 minutes where hitler couldn't do in
12 years
he wants to destroy
israel
and the jews
first
and maybe a bunch of other people second
third and fourth
and who's paying for it
you are
you're on the mileage plan
with the iranian nuclear um uh
program
i'm i'm i'm paying for it
everyone who drives a car is paying for
it
well it's not a matter of bicycle but i
did write another book called the plan
and that could be thank you and that
could be read at plan for oil crisis dot
com
i have to tell you that the reason
jewish groups are interested in this
topic
is because the reason jewish groups are
interested in this topic of oil
addiction
and here i've always devoted myself
to genocide injustice
and um
uh uh recollecting and documenting a
horrible past
to uh uh to ensure a precious future
in the case of oil addiction i am
documenting a precious past to avoid a
horrible future
almost everything you hear
about oil addiction alternative fuels
is uh from the media from government
officials from big corporation corp
corporations is either a lie
an exaggeration
or a distraction i mean most of you are
pretty interested in the gm volt which
is going to premiere some sometime next
year but the electric car was invented
in 1835 and all the cars in new york
city in in the early 1900s were electric
cars the hydrogen fuel cell from ha from
honda which is suppressing the hydrogen
car and the cng car is uh the hydrogen
fuel cell was invented in 1838
the first hydrogen bus was in 1934 the
first
hydrogen tractor was in 1956 the first
hydrogen van in 1958 the german navy has
five submarines on hydrogen hydrogen is
not the only thing the c and g there's
electric
there are many alternatives right now
right
now
we're on the verge of the outbreak of
hostilities between israel and iran and
this country has no plan for an oil
interruption barack obama doesn't have
one mccain doesn't have one the
democrats do not have one the
republicans do not have
have one the iranians are constantly
threatening to shut down the strait of
horror moves
and if they do
20 percent of the global supply 40
percent of the seabourn oil and some 20
18 to 20 percent of the american supply
will instantly stop in our strategic
petroleum
reserve will last about two months and
we don't even have a contingency plan
for it and so
i believe that what you're saying is
part and parcel which is why new israeli
leaders like netanyahu and even mccain
here in the united states saying we will
not allow a second holocaust you must
understand there's been a continuity of
oil
and holocaust since the first days of
adolf hitler including when he invaded
russia i hope that answers that who else
has a question
pardon me
[Music]
why did they switch back to gasoline
well i documented this extensively in a
book called internal combustion
um i'll give it to you short
um all the cars the united states were
electric cars
all the trucks in the united states did
you need that connected
oh
uh
you need that connected
okay so all the um
uh all the trucks were electric trucks
that were not drawn of course by
horse oh
1897 to about 1911
and henry ford had a secret plan
with thomas edison to make an electric
uh
model t
and this was all subverted by uh fire
and corporate sabotage and the forces of
internal combustion one out it's a long
story it's another 40 minute
presentation but it's in my book
internal comm combustion and
and and then why aren't they going back
now
why did they switch
they switched because i have to be
honest with you
they thought that the electric car was
so quiet
and so simple it was for girls
and they wanted a big manly car with a
big crank and a lot of noise and
everything else and this was a marketing
decision made by the people who
controlled the patents back in the
period be between
1909 and 1914
it's very well documented in my books
but the other part of it is that general
motors headed up a conspiracy
with mack truck firestone standard and
phillips in which they brought up all
the electric trolleys or some 40 of them
around the country and
tore up the rails and uh burned the
trolleys and replaced them with motor
buses for which general motors was
indicted tried convicted
and um
and that's the real reason why the
electric car was killed who else has a
question
is plan for oil crisis dot com
okay or you can just go to
edwinblack.com let me go to this lady
yes ma'am um it's just a comment my
husband is a mechanical engineer he read
uh every word of your book ibm in the
holocaust and he thinks that uh you
should focus a lot of your speeches on
university engineering departments
well i speak on eugenics to
medical groups to medical colleges
because of course this was a
fake
medical science
which was espoused at at the highest
levels of harvard uh princeton yale uh
stanford uh i do speak to uh
attorney groups about international law
about all of these things but since
genocide happens to be against
international law i do speak to
engineering groups about the hollywood i
speak to a lot of i.t groups about the
hollywood cards because most of the
people in the i.t world understand
exactly how i t works they understand
what databasing is and they understand
how easy it would be to simply identify
a person's name and cross tabulate that
name against his other characteristics
i'm just going to take two more
questions because i'm running out of
chaos here
that means uh strength for you guys who
else has got a question that didn't ask
one before
who else has got one yes one already
i'll take this one for the last one
what's your name and what's up henry
grossman
i would like to know that we know that
roosevelt did his best to disturb and
not to help the jewish people send back
ships to germany to be killed and as
well as the state department with a
bunch of sentai semis were they
influenced by all these companies that
they're the enablers of the fascist
regime in germany the question was were
all these companies where all these
politicians who were who uh uh engaged
in uh certain types of uh
passive and other types of denial and
exclusion and collaboration involving
the jewish period
are influenced by the corporate
collaborators of the third reich such as
i ibm gm etc the answer ladies and
gentlemen is yes thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
investigative reporter edwin black is
the author of many books including ibm
and the holocaust war against the week
and the plan for more information visit
edwinblack.com
all week